[Music]
my name is haifa maguffio
i am the engine manager of the flight
team
uh but you know don't get that for you
uh
i have made and continue to make commits
to most of the rippers
uh and i'm not only talking about
missing comments
um uh i'm i'm here today to
walk you through our journey of why we
built flights
um and you know touch a little bit on
the architecture
uh the you know some highlight some of
the features and
i have three demos you know lined up for
you uh
so you know what are the odds they will
work perfectly
uh but we'll see uh and then we'll
conclude
with you know hopefully uh a call to
action uh for you
um so let's get right into it this
diagram
represents data flow across various
systems that lift
and many of them are building machine
learning models uh
some of them are you know strictly doing
data processing
uh it's usually required to build you
know some other model downstream
uh probably by some other team uh each
of the boxes
of course just a simplification for
illustration like you will
uh probably recognize on these teams uh
they're like
large teams behind each of them uh i'm
not trying to
you know overshadow that um but the the
interesting uh fact i'm trying to
highlight here is
uh this is a huge system across lyft
and it's all currently powered by flight
uh we have thousands and thousands of
unique workflows uh and we like uh
we schedule millions of containers uh
every month
um and like even with the current scale
we feel we're just getting started
uh there are like many customers
internally and externally
boarding on the platform uh and you know
taking it taking the scale to a whole
new level
um just uh uh like i wanted to highlight
what where flight fits in and we
typically
start talking about ml like your ml code
uh
and you know your choice of a framework
a tensorflow party tours or you know new
judgment there
um or you know what algorithm to use and
so on and so forth
but i wanted to highlight that when we
when we talk about taking
a a model and deploying it in production
uh there are a lot more things we we
have to consider
um and those are usually not in ml
problems they are more of distributed
systems problems uh that enable your
code to
run you know at scale run reliably
repeatedly
and produce predictable results every
time
um and to zoom in a little bit on on
the one of the uh
use cases where flight fits in uh
in uh in the highlight of the you know a
typical
life cycle of an ml of developing an ml
model
uh you don't start from you know writing
the code
uh that does the machine learning right
you start from way
you know the bottom left corner here
where you have data coming into the
system
into like your company or whatever uh
and there are like different types of
data you
uh you ingest um and uh
and then you run some transformation on
them uh you do some you know prep work
clean up
you know delete like nil values and so
on um then you compute features on top
of those
uh and those are you know usually
reusable features across multiple models
and that's when you then start writing
your code or uh
discovering those features and writing
uh a model on top
um and you don't stop here of course
right you
uh you then need some continuous
monitoring for
you know both the data coming in detect
you know distribution drifting
distribution and so on
um and then of course uh like a
continuous you know feedback to you from
uh once you you ship the model to a
scalable serving
platform um you you often need to run
the c models over and over again
uh as maybe new data come in whereas you
change your code uh for any of these
steps
um and when that happens uh and
like take my word for this we have lived
through this
uh you will really appreciate not having
to you know hunt for
uh code that lives on somebody's laptop
or
uh you know and so on uh to retain those
models
and the highlight of this graph and i'm
not including all the icons for all the
tools
uh that do these steps uh but as it is
you
you see the graph is very colorful and
it's full of logos
of different systems uh that do
excellent work
uh where they fit in right um you have
you know
spark doing great in like your map
reduced jobs um
and so on uh your teams are white tours
or uh or skill learn like
whatever you use uh doing great job at
like the the
training phase um and
uh because they are very different they
don't
always uh they were not always designed
with interrupt
in mind so it's it's sometimes very hard
to
uh you know take something uh that you
know you ran on a spark job and then
massage the data so that it fits in some
other system
uh to then run the training job and feed
that back and so on
and that's where flight comes in um
flight offers uh production grade
orchestration for data and ml
uh can orchestrate code containers
scripts
queries um across all of these disparate
systems
um and the key for how we do this is we
we offer a strongly typed uh interface
stronghold type language
and definitions of the clarity language
that is language agnostic
how we use protocols um so with
having flight power uh like all of these
pipelines
enable you to connect very seamlessly
uh systems that were never meant to be
connected
uh if i may say uh to uh make these
pipelines predictable
and scale uh scale to
very large numbers uh and volumes
um when we designed flight there were a
few tenants that we
wanted to highlight or or focus on uh
it's a it's a hosted orchestration
platform um
and that takes away the need from uh you
know data scientists or
your engineers to figure out how to
deploy
an orchestration platform or how to run
it reliably or do the devops for it
they only focus on what matters to them
their business logic for
uh how these boxes connect and what to
do in each box
um it's uh it's a fabric that connects
you know all of these open source
technologies we're not open source
as you'll see later on um and it makes
it extremely easy to deploy
within your core infrastructure uh we
aim at simplifying your
auditability for the workloads and share
shareability between uh you know tasks
or common
uh common tasks that uh maybe you know
you have your
central team in in uh in your company
that develops
uh common you know algorithms or common
steps in this pipeline
uh you know maybe there's a common task
to split data
fairly right and uh or detect bias and
things like that
uh so you can share those across
different projects you don't have to
rewrite constantly rewrite things
uh or worry about dependencies uh does
it you know or conflict of dependencies
and
dependency resolution um it's uh
it's built with observability in mind so
once you ship
a pipeline to production it doesn't end
there right uh you
want to know that it's constantly
running when it doesn't run
on the schedule time and so on you want
to be notified
you want to know how much memory you
know certain tasks are using or how to
optimize this
uh workflow uh so like we built a lot of
metrics and
with a lot of thoughts into uh how we
make your
uh pipelines automatically observable uh
again not having to think about any of
these things you just think about your
business logic
and and lastly as a system the system
itself
it's the same team that built flight uh
in lyft
that also hosts flight uh so it runs the
devops for flights
and that forced us uh to also think
about uh how to do the vlogs for the
platform itself
um very well very efficiently
uh so the system itself is very
observable um
we have it's auditable you know who ran
which workflows
when and what data it accessed and all
of that
uh you know what the current loading
system is and
what is it spending time doing uh and
when there are problems happening you
know where
um there are slos that we guarantee to
the rest of the to our customers and
like all of this uh is shared
in the open source uh version of flight
uh that we released last year
um and uh i would like to like
dig a little bit deeper and try to
understand
uh flight leading up to the demo when we
start writing
uh flight codes right and there are a
few concepts
uh we should uh you should grasp first
to start off
um there is there is a notion of
organizing your flight
artifacts into projects uh so this is
the top level
entity in the system um we you can think
of projects as maybe your map for teams
in a company or you can have one team
owning multiple projects and so on
it's up to you for how to do this
partitioning but it's a it's a unit to
organize your things
uh your pipelines and tasks um and then
within those projects
uh there are domains that your flight
admin
can define they apply to all projects um
in in lyft we have the default uh flight
deployment you get development staging
production and you can think of those
as deployment rings to your own
pipelines right so you start off
uh with a new workflow or a task in the
developing domain
you iterate on it uh you know fix bugs
and try
different things try different uh
interfaces different inputs outputs and
so on
and when you are happy with what you
have uh you move it to staging and
production and that signals to you
between
the rest of your colleagues and so on
that it's it's ready for people to
use um and then we have
uh uh within those domains as i said you
have
uh workflows and tasks uh that you can
define
and uh and you can share them across
different projects and so on uh so you
can have one project you know your
common tools for email for example right
uh where you write all those tasks that
people can use and then
specific teams have their own projects
and they can just pull in those tasks to
use
uh it's very easy to search for the
tasks and workflows and there's
description and you know the ui will get
to
in a minute uh offers you like tools
around this
um uh the tasks and workflows like uh
worth probably digging it
uh digging into a bit deeper uh because
this is the fundament decided
fundamental building blocks uh
for uh for your pipelines and each task
represents an indivisible unit of
computation
uh from flight point of view uh so you
can think of them as maybe it's a single
container that runs and does something
or a query that runs in bigquery or a
press to query and so on
just like a sql query or maybe it's a
distributed spark job that will spam
multiple
containers in executors to do something
or distribute tensorflow job or maybe
calling a service like sagemaker
to run a training job there right they
can be completely different
concepts uh but the the the basic idea
is that
it has from flight point of view it has
three main components uh it has an input
interface
tells define strongly what uh inputs
you'd expect and what types those are
uh using flight typing system and it has
some execution body can be you know
a query a container and so on uh and
then it has an
output uh interface as well and uh
uh being very opinionated about how
about defining inputs
and output interfaces uh allow us to
aesthetically verify that you are um
that your entire graph uh will like you
know fit together
uh that this task can actually consume
outputs from that other task because you
know the the
interface is matched uh just like any
you know programming language with
static typing
um the the the flight typing system is
declarative
uh we are using protobox for that so you
can
uh define your tasks and workflows in
any language you want as long as you can
produce the same protobuf definitions
declaration
uh for them and in fact i like
i'm not sure if anybody from spotify is
on the call but uh
shout out to them uh spotify i think
announced
last week or the week before uh that
they are adopting flights
uh for their uh workflows as well uh
internally and
they didn't only consume what we have in
open source they immediately contributed
back
an sdk written in java that allows you
to write
tasks and workflows in java as well
besides the
default sdk we we have uh written in
python
uh so you get complete interrupt between
these two sdks
uh so somebody can write a you know
maybe a spark
scala application uh task that does one
thing and then you consume it in a
python workflow
that does something else uh one of those
steps being inspired
um on the right hand side here
uh you know we have you know just a
fictional workflow it has
you know three inputs and scrolling a
spark task and a python task and they
all look
um similar in that sense uh
they have an interface and a body and so
on um
and the workflows are composable so you
can uh
not only run tasks uh within a workflow
you can run other workflows
um there are they are dynamic you can
run you can even produce as one of the
nodes in a workflow
you can produce further nodes or further
workflows
based on you know the inputs or or some
logic you have
so it's completely flexible uh in
execution and definition languages
we provide uh a dsl in python to declare
all of this
uh to get you started but you know do
not stop there
um the there are a ton of other features
i included in the slides but i skipped
over here uh so they will be available
for you after the talk
uh to go over and you know review uh
what you missed
uh but the one thing i wanted to
highlight the other
feature i wanted to highlight is called
data catalog
it's uh it's a separate service that
also ships with flight written as part
of flight
and flight comes with you know one
implementation of that
uh but it's it's swappable you can have
your own implementation of only the
things
um and what this offers
are two very important uh uh features
for flights
uh it offers memoization uh out of box
memorization and what i mean by that
is uh at any given task you can if you
opt in for this task uh flight can
record
the inputs uh or like a signature for
the execution of this task
and the output artifacts it produced
so that if anybody else uh in the
company uh or any other workflow or in
the same workflow
ran the same task again with the same
structure the same version the same
inputs
uh it will not really run again yeah it
will automatically
reduce the outputs it produced before
and then move on
and it will you know look very seamless
from the workflow execution perspective
uh it will look like it ran but it
hasn't and you can see that in the ui of
course
but it gives you this uh added uh
benefit that you can you know iterate on
the workflow let's say you have
tens of tasks in the workflow um and
you had a bug in a in the last one of
them right
and you ran the workflow everything
succeeded the last one failed
you go you create on this fix it and
then run the entire workflow
uh and you don't want you know all the
other uh
tasks to run again uh so with this
it will like everything will look like
it ran it but it will not
and then the last one that failed before
will run and keep going
um the other important feature is
lineage and because it
is tracking all of the uh the
the inputs and what artifacts are used
where
you can uh build this tree or like
lineage tree
uh for any artifact you start from you
know very like a leaf node artifact and
tell me which work will produce that and
then from that will
tell me which artifacts it produced it's
consumed and where are they coming from
and so on and so forth
um so the the you know the email life
cycle i showed
you can look at like the very right
corner with a
with a produced model and then
tracked all the way to uh the data
tables that
uh end up produce this or the versions
of those data tables that you know
produce this model
across the system across teams and so on
um with that uh i will touch
very lightly on the basic architecture
of uh
of flight um and we have dug a little
bit deeper
on on these topics in separate talks
before
uh that you can you know look up uh so
just uh
just as a brief um glance over the
architecture it's a very classical cloud
system
uh architecture with a user plane uh
control plane and data plane
um what we uh what forms our control
pane is some is a service called flight
admin
and the console being the ui service uh
together they form this control plane
that uh
that you know that users interact with
and then they decide where executions
happen they track the entities in the
system and so on
um and then we have light propeller and
uh and that's uh a
kubernetes operator um along with you
know various operators you might deploy
on the cluster
this act as your data plane where
executions happen
um first uh it's not limited to running
things on kubernetes uh
uh there are there is a plug-in system
as i mentioned before
it's very that was one of the the
tenants when we built flights
i think it was maybe the second dock i
wrote uh
was about uh accessibility uh
in flight um and all of the
integrations flight comes with uh are
already
written in um uh with the same plug-in
model
uh so you can run you know on things on
kubernetes or elsewhere
uh and with this architecture we
have run and continue to run huge number
of workflows
uh on flight uh within lyft uh this
chart uh is i think uh goes over a year
it's already a month old uh but
with this you can see we already doubled
it shows the number of workflows we have
daily
uh it i think tripled over this one year
and uh it's probably already out of
dated
outdated and it's it's i'm not sure how
much
now how many uh workflows we run now uh
we you know lost i checked was about 40
million containers a month
uh and you know thousands of workflows
uh executions um defined and executed
and now to my favorite part uh the demos
as i mentioned i have uh three demos
lined up for you
um we will start they are the increase
in
complexity um and the the first one i
would like to start with
is something we call uh uh
a notebook task right so we we
increasingly see uh people start with
like writing their email code in
notebooks
so we wanted to meet them where they are
um and they have a set up here with the
virtual environment and jupyter notebook
and our
sdk uh in the python ez called
flight kits uh so we'll create a
notebook um
and this notebook as a whole will be
presented
to flight as one task right
not will not partition cells or anything
to run the
entire notebook as a single task um
and to achieve that we're using a
project linked source project called
papermill
shout out to these guys um uh
to to do that uh you there are
expectations about this task
right uh we use tags uh in
interpreter to indicate to flight which
cells
uh in uh represents the inputs
uh this allows us to when we launch the
the the task that we can fill in the the
real values of inputs so you don't have
to read them
uh here it will automatically happen for
you um
so you know let's say you will have uh
uh two inputs a and b and we will
perform a very
complex mathematical operation of
summing
both of them uh and then let's print
that uh
and run this you know it will use the
inputs of course you defined here
and looks good you can have as many
cells as you want here you can have
visualizations
and graphs and plot things and so on
and then the last cell has
has to be well not doesn't have to be
the last one you have to have a cell
that defines what of all the variables
you might define
you know within your notebook should be
considered as outputs
um and this might be a bit clunky and
looking for ways to
uh not have to do this uh but for now
you have to
record call flight and say record uh
this variable as the output uh for the
workflow
for you sorry for the uh the notebook
task uh you can run this and what this
does
is it it wraps your variable uh with a
protobuf
um that flight understands or can
interpret
and uh and then make available for
subsequent
tasks to consume um
the to to start using this task um i
i have written this other notebook uh so
you don't have to write it here
we will just run it and see how things
work right so
the first thing you would want to do uh
is
unit test it right if you're running it
locally on your
excuse me on your machine um and
to do so you can call this unit test
function on the the node to the defined
notebook task
with inputs right you can try different
inputs and
uh running that will just run the uh
the entire notebook you know does the
pass the inputs compute the output and
then give you back
what this the result of this variable is
uh so all looking good you know you
might have bugs here fix them and so on
uh and then what uh comes next is
i want to then run it on a cluster uh to
validate
it should run pretty much the same way
unless i do something wrong
with my uh requirements uh you know the
pip requirements or so on
uh so to do that we encourage everyone
to
always containerize their tasks uh so i
have this docker file that will include
the notebook in
uh with a version it also encourages you
to use unique versions
internally at lyft we use chars like you
as the version of the the image so you
can always tie back
the exact version of the code that
produced uh
you know workflow or pipeline uh i have
already built this before
you know so it was pretty quick uh next
up is you
uh you then register the notebook so you
tell the flight system hey i have
uh this notebook task um with
uh you know with a certain spec
um and to do that you pull this register
function with the project and domain
that the con the constructs i was
talking about earlier um
with a specific name and a specific
version um
and that gives you back a unique id that
you know anybody can
use to consume this task from a
different project a different notebook
and so on
i am connecting to a local cluster i'm
running it
on my machine in docker
and then next you can then launch it
right and it looks pretty much similar
to
how you launch how you did the unit test
except you use
launch function uh and you tell it where
to run this
um and then you pass the inputs to
the to the task um
and this gives you back a url to look at
uh for the execution
and let's go here and you know what you
a little bit
over uh through the the ui this is the
execution ui
you get at the top level the top uh
corner here the
the height the overall status of the
execution
um and then you can view the inputs uh
on the outputs when it's done uh you get
some information about the
more exclusion uh solution information
here if you are running a multi-cluster
setup
which we do in production at lyft uh you
get the cluster name here so you can
um easily know where things are and it's
already done
uh and then you get two views for the
execution there's a node view with the
list of all the nodes and the graph view
that shows you the data flow between
nodes and we'll look at a more complex
example later to
see that um you can click on the node to
see
uh to get the side panel with more
information about
the logs and if if it failed before
there are multiple attempts to run it
you get all of these here
i can see the inputs and outputs it
produced and you can see uh this task
would use output
11 because the inputs were 5 and 6.
great
um and then um and
also it automatically computes the
output
uh notebook right so if you have you
know if you
draw images or graphs or whatever in in
uh
in some cells in that notebook you can
download this and see all the outputs
computed
for all the sales the last step here is
called task and this is
from flight's point of view how you
define
uh the the task it's a protobuf
object and so it's
language agnostic uh it has an id
section it's globally addressable
within the flight system uh it has a
type some metadata and it has this
strongly typed interface with the inputs
and outputs uh the types and you know
description so on um and
uh it has this a section for what is to
execute
in this case it's a container the
command and some environment variables
and you know
yeah so we looked at the inputs here and
that was our
first demo success uh you can go back
here and uh you know we have to provide
this
convenient function to wait for the
execution if you are
um you know if you want to execute
subsequent things in
a notebook or some other way um it's
already
said it's done for my uh second
demo um i will
sorry about that um we will use a
different
task type we uh we already looked at a
notebook task
we will try a shell task right so we'll
do the same operation we did
uh this is very complex mathematical
operation of summing two numbers
uh in shell this time and uh
and then we can write we'll write a
workflow that does both of them
you can see which one finishes first
right um
so to do that you define a container
task and things should start look
familiar now you also define
inputs outputs uh interfaces right the
names of the inputs the outputs and the
types
uh the docker image the image to use and
then a command to run
um and we will automatically fight at
one time we'll substitute these with the
real values of
uh your inputs and then use this
file as the as it matches the name of
the variable
um as the value of the output uh
and if you know if it fails to uh
cast it to a float you will get a
runtime error
and then to define a workflow we uh uh
you write a class of python class uh
with this annotation
and and uh it will also look familiar
here because you define inputs
and outputs types and then the body is
like the the
the set of attributes or nodes to
execute
to um to produce this output uh in this
case i am running uh the
shell task and interactive python task
with the passing inputs
um and then pointing the outputs as
uh the outputs of these tasks and we can
launch it from here but they thought to
launch it from the ui to see how that
looks like
so this is the home page you get when
you have a flight installation
it lists all the projects you can search
for them you get the domains and login
uh i don't have login enabled in my
local setup
um i register this workflow in flight
snacks right so i can go
there and you get the view of the
project with the
with two uh panels for workflows and
tasks
uh i only have this one workflow
registered you click on that
and you get a view of all the past
executions for workflow you can filter
and so on
and you can launch that um you get you
can pick the version
um you have two versions registered and
it automatically picks the last one
um we can run
uh can give inputs and um
and execute this workflow takes you to
the
uh execution page um right
which looks similar now uh with both of
them
and if you look at the graph here they
are running in parallel
uh because there is no dependency
between the two tasks they are both
consuming the
inputs from the workflow um and you get
so this already started with logs and so
on uh
this one is still waiting uh when
they're done
you will get views like success uh
for these five seconds and this is a
minute that's
it's only because uh this rant first um
and on my local machine don't have
capacity to run both of them in parallel
uh so this waited um so it took longer
uh with that and that is my second demo
um and for third demo be really quick
i will not try to run anything we'll
just uh walk through it
um a more real example of uh uh of a
training workflow
uh in this example i have a graph that
runs a
two tasks to pull in data and then
convert the data
uh from 4k format to csv then run the
uh run a training algorithm um in
incident here in amazon
interview stage maker um and then
produce the outputs
being the model right and you get links
here for uh
you know to access uh stage maker and
monitor your job
in the platform as it's running uh you
can see the logs and so on
while things are happening and to
do all of this uh i wrote this this will
happen again on a notebook
and we make all of these notebooks
available in
in flight snacks repo
with you know more documentation about
how things
work uh for this i wrote a presto task
and
again things should look familiar
they're inputs
in this case they're empty and i have a
query um
and i registered the task and i have
another task that gets the
you know variation data from a different
table
of course in real time in real examples
this will not be the case you will
pull all the data and you have some
split function uh
but just for you for simplicity's sake
uh and then
for the the conversion to uh from parque
to csv
i am using a task you know somebody else
wrote
i am also i'm just fetching it uh
so you need to know the the unique id
for this task
the project domain is defined and the
name and the version of this
you're kind of pinning uh to this
version
of the task and from this point
on you can use it just like any other uh
task you define yourself
um and then for the training job the
training task
step uh we define a stage maker task uh
that you know we wrote as part of
integration with sagemaker
um you create the training task and then
we created a
hyper parameter tuning on top of that
training task uh and then registering
that
um and then you write a workflow that
does all that runs out of this right you
you just
get the data and pass the data to this
conversion function get back csv then
call the hpo task
uh and then finally the cleared out
being the model
of this workflow um and i launched it
from here
and you get back an execution url and
you can wait for it and
you know look at the uh you can use the
model for like look at prediction if you
want
later on i'm using data uh from this
open source data set um and
uh the first time i wrote this uh it it
failed
uh at the conversion because and you get
the error here i wanted to show you that
you know um demos don't work all the
time
um uh and the otherwise it is like
well i forgot to push this image that i
built
uh so at front time it failed to pull
the image got me an error
i fixed that and next time uh you can
see the first time the the
press two tasks first to queries ran
next time when i
fixed this and ran it again uh they
didn't run
right they were all cast you get success
immediately
and then it ran from with a field before
uh doing those training and gradation
you know conversion and then the
training task
um just to point and that took about 11
minutes and then i read on it once more
uh and just like everything has been
cast already
so nothing ran uh but it succeeded right
away
and with that um
i think i would call them with success
um i uh uh we
as we as things stand uh this is kind of
our
ecosystem and it's like uh expanding
very quickly and uh um and
like it humbles us when we see you know
open source contributions
uh that added uh the tensorflow
integration or pytorch and so on
some of them are built by us some like
these two or not um
and uh we currently run flight is an aws
shop we run everything on
aws but our friends at spotify
run flight on gcp so we know it works
just
as well on gcp uh they help us get there
we we haven't partnered with anyone who
runs on azure but
you know if you do please give it a shot
uh it should be agnostic to all the you
know the differences between
uh these cloud providers um
uh and yeah and we're looking forward to
more uh more integrations
added to it uh so what's next where do
you go from here
uh there are a ton of things that are
lined up we're working on
uh as we speak uh the the flight kit
java is already released thanks to
spotify
uh we're working on more visualizations
for data catalog to show the lineage and
so on
uh ui improvements and you know and so
on and so forth
uh we made those all available in the
open source flight repo
if you go to github slash flight lift
flight
um where you go you just uh the one-stop
shop to
to learn about everything flight is why
don't work um
it's uh you know things are we are
like maybe eight months in uh after the
open source but we are just
getting started and uh i i can't wait to
see what you will build
uh on flights thank you